[Music]  i got to say one of my favorite things  about watching the olympics i don't know  if you think the same but all the super  slow-motion video they use for the  instant replays the technology is so  amazing  and they get it so slow and then they  add majestic music and it makes anything  look really cool  and that got us thinking why can't we  get in on that okay so we did this  before once again we rented one of those  super slow-motion olympic cameras and  recorded our own great moments take a  look  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  okay  [Applause]  you